good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that thing you've got
inside you explode out into the universe
to have a big impact and so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn how to live in the moment and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
how do I be more present it's a
fantastic question and let me
distinguish really quickly before we
jump into how the the difference between
the past the present and the future if
you're living in the past you're going
to be depressed because you are
rehashing things that happen to you that
are not going to happen again if you're
living in the future you're gonna be
anxious because you are anticipating
what's coming or you're wishing for
things that aren't happening yet being
in the present is where the gold is
being in the present moment is where you
will have the greatest control where you
will feel the most at ease and where
happiness flourishes there's a super
tight connection between happiness and
the ability to live in the present
moment a lot of people believe that
happiness is tied to the things that
happen to you not so at all 40% of your
happiness levels are preset by genetics
60 percent you are in complete control
of
there are many little things you can do
to access the power of the present
moment for example a very simple thing
us ask yourself am I still breathing
and you suddenly feel the air flowing
into your body and out of your body hmm
yes I'm breathing at that moment you've
entered the state of presence even if
it's only five seconds you've entered
that you've become present in the moment
in that moment so another thing I
suggest is when you do think a bit your
everyday motions like washing your hands
or walking across the room or walking
down the stairs or the slightest thing
taking a cup out of the cupboard do it
consciously do it being present of every
how it the feel of for example you wash
your hands feel the water smell the soap
yes becoming acutely conscious of sense
perceptions which means looking hearing
touching if also brings you into the
present moment and the more you bring
those moments of presence into your life
the more your old conditioning becomes
eroded gradually I see so learning to do
it with washing your hands I just
grapple things this is good this class
is good for me I got it now but just
learning to do the simple things begins
to retrain your mind yes and another
thing is most simple things that you do
which actually fill up most person's
everyday life because the whole day
consists of simple things that you have
to do right they're all relatively
simple right and the way most people
live is that everything you do is a
means to an end at the end is where you
want to get to the next moment right so
you're never thinking about the moment
no you because you want to get to the
next one you're bossing your hand in
order to already do that or you're
making while you're making a cup of
coffee we
really want to be drinking it and then
everything you do is a means to an end
the end is always the next moment in the
future which never arrives because all
you ever have in life is the present
moment as it moment so you're constantly
frustrated yes creating anxiety for
yourself and stress because you can't
just be present resume being present is
literally nothing more than the skill of
having your thoughts be in this moment
not in the past
not in the future but right here the way
that you teach yourself how to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself being distracted the moment you
catch yourself starting to worry the
moment you catch yourself drifting to
the future drifting to the past that's a
moment of tremendous power because you
basically just woke up
you basically just notice that you're
not here in this particular moment so
use that wake-up call 5 4 3 2 1 and
ground yourself in this moment the best
way to ground yourself in the moment is
to look for something in this particular
moment that you can savor now I'm using
the word savor on purpose because it's
the word that psychologists use to
describe what happens when you find
something in this moment right now right
here right now to focus on and to
appreciate it could be literally the
questions these are these are printed
out questions from people on social
media and if I were to stop and look at
these and savor them what I would feel
in this moment is a tremendous amount of
gratitude because people are taking the
time to write and that makes me feel
incredibly grateful and it also makes me
very happy because it means that that
the folks that are writing are taking
control of their lives and seeking out
the information that they need another
form of savoring that we can all relate
to is eating as you're eating instead of
drifting to the future and thinking
about all the things that you need to do
or hanging out in the past and rehashing
everything that's happened during the
day be in this moment in this meal slow
down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with and how you feel about them
and if you want to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge okay this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
I'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
those small simple acts of savoring are
how you expand your happiness inside the
present moment so how do you be more
present simple the moment that you catch
yourself in the future in the past
worrying whatever refocus yourself right
here right now and then find something
right here right now that you can savor
and when you do that you're not only
going to be present you're gonna feel
more grateful and you're gonna feel a
little boost to happiness if you want to
be truly present and benefit from
appreciating your daily life you must
develop an attitude of gratitude the
habit of feeling grateful and expressing
that gratitude to other people by saying
thank you to those in your life and to
yourself for all of the wonderful things
in your life every day will have an
amazing effect on your personality and
your ability to live in the present an
attitude of gratitude makes you a warmer
friendlier and more genial person an
attitude of gratitude makes you more
sensitive and more aware of others
around you and your environment the more
gratitude you have and the more
gratitude you express the happier and
brighter your life will become when we
are thankful to others and Express a
wonderful attitude to those around us on
a regular basis we can change the lives
of others as well as our own focus is
driving everything in your life you got
to get back it's not just about being
productive we'll talk about that it's
about experiencing the best quality of
life you hear this new movement called
the mindfulness movement write about the
new popularity of these conversations
about presence and and meditation and
and things like myself and my industry
have been talking about for decades well
you hear about that that's really just
about reigning back in control of our
focus and
that's gone mad and crazy and distracted
so how are you gonna get your focus back
well let me give you some
counterintuitive ways to do it the first
thing that I need you to know in order
to get your focus back is to realize
that you need to make fewer decisions
fewer decisions why well as we know and
from neuroscience and we know from
productivity studies that the more
decisions that we actually make the more
our brain becomes fatigued right the
more decisions that we make the more we
utilize the glucose that's really
fueling our willpower that's fueling our
frankly our our ability to make more
decisions and higher quality decisions
matter of fact the more decisions that
you tend to make the less effective
you're going to be over the long term
because you're gonna utilize your
ability and your resources and your
brains power literally your willpower
will go out the window
so you want to minimize the number of
decisions you are making how do you do
that well here are some simple things
one stop browsing you know I know maybe
you found me because you were browsing
somewhere and I hope you make me part of
your focus on your personal development
then I'm a per proof so part of your
life but I can tell you overall browsing
completely wipes out your focus and your
willpower even all these little things
you're focusing on are utilizing all
your brain's resources and over time
when you stop browsing and you go back
to focusing on something guess what you
tend not to be able to focus on one
thing and get things done you start
multitasking and doing lots of things
but where your work isn't really focused
nothing gets accomplished so what
happens is your brain is fatigued guess
what happens your brain fatigue you find
yourself sitting with a bag of data
chips and what do you do when you have
the remote control you're just flipping
randomly through things do you ever
notice that meaning it's easier to
become distracted the more distracted
you are meaning the more that you aren't
focusing on one thing
at a time the more problem you're going
to have later on to complete one thing
at a time and I know that makes sense
but here's this simple solution if you
missed it
stop browsing so much all those browsing
all those tweets that you're reading all
those news feeds that you're reading
guess what every time you look at them
that's what your mind has to do it has
to make a decision
pay attention or not pay attention and
that decision is costing you focal power
and resources later on even if you don't
know it if you can't learn to appreciate
the moment you'll never be happy I think
one of the things that we as
entrepreneurs are great at is being
frustrated with the status quo is
wanting more it's one in the change
something one of the change the way an
industry is done because we're so angry
and frustrated with how it's currently
being done and that's great and that's a
strength and that's a tool we should
lean in on it at the same time though I
want you to be grateful for what you do
have to recognize the abundance of
opportunities and wealth that you have
already living the fact that you are
living and watching this video and have
access to YouTube puts you ahead of
still most of the world and recognizing
that and being so grateful that if even
if you never accomplished any more of
your goals that you have an amazing life
I think it's helpful now I don't think
it's only focused on how great
everything is because then you don't do
anything else right you don't want to
change things that little bit of
frustration is good but I think you need
both I think too many people don't lean
too hard on the negative on the
frustration on the way things are
currently done and if that's all you are
chasing then you'll never be happy
there's a great story from tech not hang
where he's talking about washing the
dishes to wash the dishes he's doing
this retreat with his students and at
the end of every night they'll go over
to his place and he would make them
dinner and then he would wash the plates
and one of the guys who came to his
session said hey let me wash the place
for you you did a lot of work you helped
us out you fed us how about I wash the
plates for you and he told them that if
you're gonna wash the plates that you
need to wash the plates you wash the
plates to watch the plates and what that
means is so many times when people are
washing the plates what are you doing
you're thinking of what's next
and you're not actually focused on
Washington please
I think you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I love to know what do
you think of this video what did you
take home that you were going to
immediately apply somehow into your life
for your business please leave it down
the comments below I would love to hear
from you I also want to give a quick
shot at too many via from 2000 books
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and sharing
that beautiful picture on Twitter I
really really really appreciate the
support and I'm so glad you enjoyed the
roof thank you guys again for watching
have an amazing day
I believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
when we talk about living in the moment
we've heard this from great sages and
occupy the present right but how do we
do that how can we just forget about
maybe something really bad just happened
to you I don't know you didn't win the
lottery it happens right first world
problems right we're gonna do a video on
that occupying the present starts with
breathing in that beautiful prana that's
what's helped me it starts with being
aware and sensitive of your senses right
what are you eating right now what are
you hearing right now what are you
saying right now what are you touching
right now are you in tune with that why
are you too busy staring at the cat down
the road can I get a hello there right
become in tune with your sensations
because if you keep having flashbacks of
golden times like I do a lot what
happens you start walking into people oh
why don't you just do that oh sorry I
was just thinking of a golden age can I
get a Hello there that's no excuse
[Music]
so if you could look at it like this you
are exactly where you need to be be
patient and hold on start to embrace
your natural state of being in life your
normal natural healthy state of being
alive is a wonderful gift and should be
treated that way so try to tune into the
amount of joy you experience and the
number of times you laugh on a daily
basis to demonstrate the fullness of
your current life position acknowledge
these moments and be grateful for them
each time that they happen eventually
reacting to these positive moments with
gratitude will become a habit and you
will start to feel a happier all the
time as soon as you're aware that you
have left meaning you're hanging out you
know maybe having a conversation with
someone and all of a sudden you know
your experiences of that person talking
is like packing around and you're just
like thinking about something later or
you're judging them or you no longer
hear them and you go on it and it on a
tangent or you can be for example may if
I'm in the shower very dangerous place
because my mind will just start
wandering if I don't catch it right just
working with people with this for over
20 years it's pretty much everybody has
the same set of thoughts that their mind
goes to if it just starts wandering off
and it all basically comes down to that
I suck right it's like you know you're
about to go into a meeting it's like
your mind will go all the terrible
things you know how worthless and
pointless you are both applause it's
just like where our minds tend to go
right so there's no good to come out of
listening to that nonsense and so
basically I'm back is as soon as you're
aware that you've left you say it in
committed impulse class you say it out
loud people just go I'm back and it's
really good news it's like it's like
you've just like
you know gone shopping and
Bloomingdale's and it's like I'm back
I'm actually here right and it's just
like an incredibly powerful tool to to
stay present the most important work
ever if you have to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]